there's so much i need to say amelia
hamlin is responding to critics who are
accusing her of black fishing
the 19 year old model who is currently
dating scott disick
recently shared this series of photos to
instagram
where some fans point out that her skin
tone appears darker than usual
a concept known as black fishing it's a
term
partly coined by journalist wanna
thompson that describes
non-black influencers and stars using
makeup
fake tanner photoshop or even surgery to
give off the appearance that they are
black
or mixed race several hours after
sharing the photos
emilia took to her instagram story to
respond to the criticism
writing quote i recently went on
vacation to the sun and with my
italian heritage i tan very easily there
is no self-tanner involved or
intention of looking darker than my own
natural skin color
i had a lot of fun creating this look
with no malice intention
or offense emilia also thanked her
critics for educating her
on the topic controversy aside the
model's been keeping busy with boyfriend
scott disick
the two recently returned from a trip to
miami along with his three children
11 year old mason eight-year-old
penelope and six-year-old
reign at the end of the day i mean you
just want to be happy
you want to be content and although a
source previously told et that the pair
is still
not super serious they're having a blast
together
[Music]